a good game show is a well-oiled million
dollar machine built to ensure both fun
and fairness but with tons of cash on
the line some contestants just can't
resist the urge to find a way to beat or
cheat the system and win big here are a
few of the biggest game show cheaters in
history or at least the ones who were
caught Charles Ingram Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire really wants contestants to
win since it's just good TV to see a
regular Joe get rich even with multiple
lifelines available to contestants for
especially difficult trivia questions
that just wasn't enough for disgraced
Army Major Charles Ingram who appeared
in the British edition of the show in
2001 according to vice Ingram station
two people in the audience his wife
Diana and his friend tequan widok both
former contestants as he carefully read
off each of the four multiple-choice
answers out loud he'd listened for a
cough which was allegedly a signal from
his plants as to which answer was the
correct one
using this ridiculous method pioneered
by cheating high school students Ingram
actually won the million pound grand
prize the scheme was ultimately
discovered in all three were found
guilty of quote procuring the execution
of a valuable security by deception or
in simpler terms fraud all three
received suspended prison sentences and
were fined a combined total of 55,000
pounds which Charles allegedly never
paid Ingram was also stripped of his
title by the army board after 17 years
of service as if that weren't enough bad
karma Charles Ingram later slipped on an
apple while mowing his lawn and cut off
three of his toes sorry Charlie Adriana
Albania in 2014
Spanish model adriana albania appeared
on pasa palabra Spain's version of
password albania's blatant cheating
scheme occurred during a segment where
she had to listen to song clips and
identify the name and performer the game
had barely started when the host and
other contestants noticed that she kept
looking at a phone she had hidden in her
lap she been using the music
identification app Shazam
she was called out on it right on the
show but everyone just laughed it off
the host Kristen Galvez even said that
she deserved a special prize for
cheating so brazenly a few days later
Albania made her intentions clear saying
no one told me that I could not cheat
you also have to understand that it was
to help someone
I'm very altruistic Colette Elka tetiny
millionaire hotseat is an Australian
spinoff of Who Wants to Be a Millionaire
and in 2014 a cocky 19 year old law
student named Khalid Al Capp tetany
appeared on the show and racked up
winnings of $100,000 I only get fifty
did I get the cellar front after the
show aired he told the media that he
cheated Lasorda
saying I didn't play the game I played
the man huh according to Elka tetiny he
claimed to nail correct answers to the
questions not through knowledge but by
watching the body language of hosts
Eddie McGuire as he read off the
multiple choice possibilities omitting
if you look at it you see me working
Eddie McGuire I'm reading every single
subtle thing about his face he also
watched the studio audience behind the
guire to see which choice made their
faces light up in the end Elka tetiny
got to keep his money because utilizing
a poker strategy for a trivia game
technically isn't against the rules when
asked about his plans for his winnings
Elka tetany simply said quote I didn't
win anything
I earned it Terry nice The Price is
Right seems like a difficult game show
to win because it involves guessing the
quote actual retail price of items which
never seem to be anywhere near what
you'd see in an actual retail store
so when Terry knees put in a bid of
23,000 $743 during a showcase showdown
in 2008 and hid the prizes retail price
exactly it defied all the odds how'd he
do it
Esquires profile of niece revealed his
secrets
the man is an analytical genius niece
has been both an expert blackjack player
and an award-winning li accurate
meteorologist I'm Terry nice you may be
better off sitting at home roasting your
nuts on an open fire than going out on
the roads tomorrow
nice told Esquire that he his wife
recorded episodes of The Price is Right
every day for four months then memorized
the prices of all the items the show
used and frequently reused in the
showcase showdown segment from there it
was just basic math it wasn't even a new
strategy how did you settle on 21-14 out
over last weekend that was exact price I
host Drew Carey floated another theory
in the audience during the taping was
Ted Slauson a regular price attendee and
one-time contestant who had also amassed
an encyclopedic memory of showcase
prices Carey and show producers seem to
think that Slauson colluded with nice
and use hand signals to tell him the
perfect price an allegation that both
men deny nice got to keep his winnings
because despite their suspicions Joe
couldn't prove he did anything wrong
other than being really good at math
korilla BBQ in 2011 the New York
city-based food truck korilla BBQ was
eliminated from the great food truck
race a reality show competition in which
hopeful Street chefs compete for a grand
prize of $50,000 the team of the lowest
sales gets eliminated hence Kirill is
desperate if not ill-conceived attempt
at staying alive with some bogus profit
unfortunately
20 guys for the chief it was clear that
you put 2700 dollars of your own money
in the tell the owners of the Korean
Mexican fusion truck maintained their
innocence despite a confidentiality
agreement that barred them from speaking
out in too much detail Food Network
originally only said that the team was
eliminated from the show after making
quote an unfortunate decision it wasn't
until a 2016 interview with Korean
American story org that korilla BBQ
owner Eddie song finally cleared up what
really happened
apparently the team decided to get
creative when facing the challenge of
not being able to sell meat while
competing in Memphis song and his crew
quote formed a little partnership with
one of the top memphis-style barbecue
joints and ended up selling empty
tortillas and sending the customers
elsewhere to get free meat ultimately
they bent the rules and got busted the
21 gang while most gameshow cheats are
simply over eager rogue contestants the
scandal surrounding the 1956 game show
21 involved the show's producers and
served as the basis for the 1994 movie
quiz show
according to Charles Van Doren's New
Yorker account of the scandal producers
al Friedman Jack Barry and dan Enright
colluded with contestants herb Stempel
and Charles Van Doren in some carefully
choreographed high-stakes game show
drama after around six weeks of coach
winning force temple the show saw dip in
ratings possibly due to the unlikable
nature of the quirky New York postal
clerk enter Charles Van Doren a handsome
English professor from Columbia
University and the son of a prominent
poet he was similarly coached and after
some staged episodes that ended in Ty's
bendure and eventually overtook stemple
both contestants walked away with a
bunch of cash and ratings were up
win-win right wrong no one believes
stempel's claims about the plague of
gameshow fixing until a notebook full of
future quiz answers was found on the set
of a completely different game show
stemple testified to a grand jury which
eventually led to congressional hearings
and an amendment to the Communications
Act of 1934 making it officially illegal
to fix quiz shows it didn't much matter
because the networks were so spooked but
they abruptly canceled many of their
primetime game shows anyway we're
looking for nuts now
we're looking for nuts nuts
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]